this year's Nobel Peace Prize is  recognizing efforts to end sexual  violence during wartime it was awarded  to dr. Denis mukwege ah and Nadia Murad  Isis forces in Iraq kidnapped and raped  Marah back in 2014 she escaped after  three months and then began telling the  world how she and her people were  targeted Mook Vega has treated thousands  of women who were raped during decades  of conflict in Central Africa he talked  about them with Anderson Cooper 60  minutes back in 2008 she said you know  they're in deep pain but it's not just  physical pain its psychological pain  that you can see here at the hospital  we've seen women who've stopped living  for all the people you know the Prize  Committee says Moo rod and Mook Vega put  themselves at risk to show how women are  used as a weapon of war I remember that  interview they both really opened the  world is a major crises